哈囉大家就為了插一箱來了
現在我身後載了超級多
這次買了非常非常多的村莊馬上開拆
這是我買的Ruffler人他們家非常獲得亞馬的趁山是帶小樓狗的
這個是S嘛
S嘛居然還要排齊
這件是被秀金妹子重草的
就是穿上上感覺非常的隨性
就很有用的喊味
它這個亞馬的就是
我以為沒運動的
如果這樣好像好看一點
還買了他們家一件這個非常經典的這種真至開山
就是在想說一搜網馬上重草
又休閒
但是又很舒逆
我覺得他們家這個開山的話
你稍微前面錄一點點
這個胸口然後會顯得人
特別受人會把人的肩膀顯得稍微寬一點
就會顯得頭肩筆
非常地好
回色編織的毛衣
我覺得它的顏色非常震
而且它這件我覺得這個有這種老前風的感覺
它澳的馬術
它一定要穿的就是非常的寬鬆
才有那種
永懶的感覺
但他們家它買了一點
這種灰色的帽感
這個顏色非常的適合我
我就很適合這種灰掉的顏色衣服拆
這個是在iCo的直播間
重草的一件真知的提醒
我這種淡人就非常適合了這種淡色
第一個是一條白色的亞馬的酷子
這個才是我覺得摩擦挺舒服的
它沒有想像中那種永懶亞馬的那種感覺
就好像是那種
早上去公園裡面打太極穿的那種酷子
這是我在想書刷到隨便買的一件白色的提醒
非常有女人為了一件
想要酷過的算也可以
它會有一點個性在裡面
這個也是在直播間下單的穿起來
我覺得會更有設計感一點
然後它做那一搭我覺得也挺好看的
它是這個羊毛的材質還不錯
我又在連卡坡買了兩件Skinsa
提醒他們家的這個系列的提醒
它只要出一件我就會買一件暗星特別好
都寫了人整個歐圖有制
然後買了兩個顏色
之前買過黑色
這個是他們家的一個有一點灰卡色
這也是Skinsa他們家的一件
這件這種非常短版的落落的材質
新加坪還不錯
特別還買酷子
而且我喜歡穿這種酷腿酷
我覺得會把我的比規顯得更好
然後腿線的更細
這道酷子我就還不錯的
這個也是戰小書刷到我的
自帶雙電的這種背形
做的顏色全買
我覺得它這個面的料都很舒服
做的是非常精緻
除了它自帶雙電
然後有一點壓附魯之外
我覺得沒這麼缺點
做那一搭就行了
只物的話顏色是這種膚色很好看
然後白色就不用說了
非常非常的白的
你看它這個面料做的多餓細質
這件是歐陽娜娜同款的一個
真吃的露背的調代
我以為這件是LV的
就沒想到
這樣是一個網絡品牌
但是我覺得它的質感是蠻好的
這是一條真絲的綠色的群子
背心在上面是一套
這件真絲的上面
我覺得還挺乖的眼
顯得挺甜美挺乖巧的
這次我買的用衣
今天想去淺水
爆了個油用課
然後就買了一些用衣
這個顏色我覺得挺好看的
非常的橙膚色
就是很清晰
很適合春天
都是留於非代言那個貓人的那一品牌之後
我就馬上下擔了
你就送了好多證品
他們家的一個洗衣造吧
留意非的小卡片
這件有一個顏色我覺得很亮眼
它是這種
這邊是咖啡色
然後上面是那種添藍色
跳色會沒那麼無聊
接著最近我們以上的新興人
東東東東東東
東東東東
三端
這裡是1、2、4代
其實還有一個三代在路上
但是我是在是等不及了
先從1代開始把我看看
擁要這個運氣拆出隱藏款
6個
開始了
東東東東的第一個是什麼
應該是小太陽吧
小太陽也不錯
再來
又不是隱藏這是什麼
這是小擔心
小擔心
小哈勁
小哈勁很可愛
小哈勁是我在這裡面
其實我對喜歡的一個
可愛
好長和長的帽子
好
再來
這是什麼
小超人
從目前還沒有拆到小可愛
我已經用兩個小可愛了
我不想再拆到小可愛了
你來看一下
小猫咪現在
一、二、三、七小可愛
再來最後兩次機會了
小幸運
這是小幸運嗎
這最後一個到底是小可愛
還是隱藏款
我已經用兩個小可愛了
三個小可愛了
那好吧既然我有三個小可愛的話
來一個寶貝
二、帶
開拆
二、帶的隱藏款是小氣球
小氣球,小氣球
哦,壞皮氣
好吧看起來皮氣真的是有夠壞
第二個
這個看起極像小氣球耶
這是
爛衝起黃爛
每一個都覺得長得很像小氣球
爛衝起長了
有很可愛
再來
我就不幸運
裝了三個
六、一、二、三
小潮血道
也很可愛啦
其實我沒有覺得那個隱藏款
有什麼好看的
就是隱藏款嘛
就是想要
但是這個也很可愛
挖放包上不知道
讀得很好看的來
這個包裝是這樣子的
我覺得這個應該是隱藏款了
我愛去挖補
掉了天大的牙
不讀
綠色的出不出
拆的時刻
被小型搭合在那邊看了一眼
我是隱藏
我這個小卷嗎
是這樣子的吧
最後一個
這一盒咱們就是端完了
電話、招大廚
後面還有一個
綠色的小蝴蝶杞
四代了
四代我超喜歡的
四代我覺得它很小巧
哇
四代的包裝是這樣子的
不倒爪
端了
我覺得這個我
肯定能拆到一場
這個是甜奶油
餅乾
先取勤
我咖啡也喜歡的
做有後三個
咱今天拆了18個
能不能拆出一場款
對的最後這十張個
香草脆
哇香草脆是藍眼睛
我喜歡
看顏色就不是
綠色的
莫茶蘇
不是小三領的顏色
最後一個的
非常有細菌性的
不是
顏色脆
我也喜歡的紅紅色
雖然沒太重女藏
但是一次性
開始八個
也是很爽的
這個是被全之前
才也重草的一個
應該是那種
代高光的塞紅
我們個人受關書
蜜桃的顏色
高光
非常地好看
水光斷光的那種妝感
就你自己上來一點
下半
欸不錯欸不錯
真不錯
很輕透的感覺
這個我記得才幾十塊錢吧
沒想到效果這麼好
這是我
想想說被重草的一個
非常小種的有色面雙
因為特本想給大家出一集
有色面雙的合集
目前還沒有找到說
非常非常好用的有色面雙
很輕寶位 很輕透位
對比一下看
這邊是我上了兩層
然後這邊是素眼
這邊它的雲服效果還蠻好的
會有一點點的
這種修飾
但是又是非常非常自然的
對於早八人來說還是蠻方便的
因為它用手就可以直接
非常好的圖欲了
它才一百多塊錢
但是我好似
這個是我買的一個眼線一張
還可以
用小象中的好一點
就是它畫的不是特別的
故意整吧
但是
遠看我覺得是不錯的
畫裝技術不好
就是老買這些偷懶的東西
這個是兩半畫裝
刷搶搶搶暗用鼻影上
好的話跟大家分享
我之前做過一期畫裝包分享
然後我的摘
畫裝包就被我偷用
他們拿走了
所以我又重新買
它可以直接展開榮亮特美大
就是有仔細把它全部吸下來
它可以讓你所謂的東西全部都數著
在你能面前
你退房的時候不是很忙
來不及畫裝
直接畫在你
經歷箱上
然後它就變成了
一個移動式的畫裝台
非常方便
等等
比如說你出門三四天
小旅行的時候
你就直接帶它就行了
你就拿去摔小武藏劇權
然後也可以讓你所有的產品
全部都數著
擺在裡面的錢
但是這種
大家現在可以詞吸的
非常方便
這也是幾十塊錢
原汁還很高嫩
我爆了一個線上的方僚客
因為我真的很喜歡
經由方僚的組織
給我們的一些上課的資料
這六隻裡面
我最愛的就是
這個淋魂的回當
其妙的味道
它有點像中藥的味道
很穿很穩
然後我也回購了一個症狀
新買了一條
反客牙寶的一個
新款的
Lucky
非常非常穿天的一條
是不是
特別特別的穿天
最喜歡的
就是中間的藍色的蝴蝶
我覺得就是
點精之筆
蝴蝶長非常地美容
我現在把它帶上
畫好好看
它這是蝴蝶
然後
旁邊這裡是小花花
小葉子
這裡也是小花花
這是非常非常春天的一條
這次還在相當的買了一點東西
給大家拆一下看看
現在是買了一個
小包包
這個三一百
以前兩年的時候
就被種草了
剛好
專櫃它有黑色了
我就適合一下
發現因為我很喜歡
所以我就把它拿下了
它這個是
可言可顯得一隻小包包
有兩年滿大的蠻能裝的
這就很喜歡
在就是還買了一點
他們家的帽子
我覺得這裏帽子
會比剛才
這個
Ruff law人的
更貼合我的臉形一點
Ruff law人是感覺
休閒一些
相當的這個呢
會感覺
更精緻一點
這個應該是
品牌裏盒
讓我給我記得
應該是他們家新出的訪賽
也是這種春天的包裝
跑春天
好喜歡這顏色
應該是這個是
種的
可以
種種花花菜
就他們家應該是自己
有給我們
這裡面應該是種子
一塊圈好輕輕的
帶一下看看
好想這個放圈好看的
好春天
接下來是這個
斯大補送我的
新年裏盒
是他們家的大白貫
我很喜歡用他們家
大白貫
種而不膩
它裡面有這種款式的
毛融融的
這個是一個小
漢堡小小的
和字装的
就是每次空的
把大白貫
挖在這裏用
好可愛
也可以做一個小包罐
這個盒子
裡面還有一個小小的
這個是他們家的
任福魯
這個應該是魯業壯的
然後大白貫是雙壯的
這個呢
我就留著自己用
還有一個
這個50050克的大白貫
這個就
瑪董的
哦
這個好像是
背得馬星
寄給我的
同家的一個新品
一個控油魯
好用的話後面跟大家分享
這是B孫之間
他們家的新款吧
一個護唇膏
白玉藍線定
拿到手裡面
看著這個顏色
覺得心情特別好
真的就是很春天的感覺
我在手上試一下
感覺滿認的
香味也很清晰
好用之後跟大家分享
這個我知道是什麼
我有一個非常愛喝的一個酒的品牌
毛臺下面的
他們是做那個藍梅汁的
我之前在年獲姐的時候
跟大家分享過
然後這他們家的證品
說你買他們家酒會送你杯子
杯子是送的用
好漂亮
他們家的酒油
四個口味
藍梅的
然後玫瑰立之的
用子的和清局烏龍的
我個人最愛的是
藍梅的又子的
非常非常的好喝
度數又不是很高
女生喝或者全家一集喝
都挺不錯的
買了一個
新年小買的手機客
好可愛的
這個小買
車愛吃蠻過的
我想說說到一個注農的一個體驗子
他們說這個蠻過的
很好吃
就買來試一試
是一瓶嗨眼
因為我看越染的視頻
它分享了一個
感染油
香草冰淇淋的吃法
要用到香草冰淇淋
還有嗨眼和感染油
非常簡單
就很適合這種染源
最後這個
知讓
BF所有事情都需要上去
也很好吃
最後一個是什麼呢
我買的一個
醒花眾花的眾一樣一
就每次我的花
如果有他們家一樣一
就可以多待一會
他們家這個新下比很高
還配得中小兩杯
好了
今天的拆香就拆完了
不知道大家看得爽不爽呢
反而我是拆得很爽了